welcome to this video plink plank p z10
never played him before no statistics
and he's from Paraguay Paraguay don't
have that too often let's see yeah it's
a triangle let's see if he's going for
form stone warrior let's say I play this
counter stone wall it's not done
particularly great but at least it's
relatively easy to play hmm ok not so
sure if this is helping him EDI take f5
and see takes d5 I have not be five and
this looks a bit tricky for black
doesn't it o Queen a 6 mm I should have
plagued cone a six this would have been
would have been even better
yeah it's it's nice anyway but hmm I
think Queen a6 was even better than he
never gets to play a six
down here it's of course okay for white
but it's nothing particularly exciting
hmm
mmm now i'm not sure 95 is not really
need to lead to much
don't see a way forward at the moment
hmm yeah that's not be care how you can
play g5 even I forgot about that one mmm
check
yeah it's not not much happening really
and wait isn't this X hanging Quincy one
Queen f1 and it's a piece and if it
takes here 96 takes on d 396 and I can
just take it 96 takes why is God d2 at
the end sorry i miscounted really
miscounted here okay but I've got queen
bee three which attacks d6 andy sixx
yeah and what what is his move now check
i go to h 2 black resigned yes there's
no move I don't they don't see one as
well you can try um check I can try
ahead but this is really not not much
going on after that this look we need
six here it was surprising end to this
to this game I don't think yet I didn't
have any way he could play g5 as I
mentioned oh it's not good interesting
taking is good and then still 94 aha why
I'm over this I never would have seen
that one the idea is to play here having
the shock this check no way I would have
played that so g5 was not good but I
wouldn't have seen that very sure about
that well this is not not as convincing
but um still Jan shouldn't play what
should you be maybe night df6 it's very
close this position so he shouldn't
really be in now in enormous trouble I'm
always a bit more comfortable like this
I can do that and this is simply a
better piece than the bishop here and
the c6 week and so on but then it should
be it should be very dry I think I am I
let something slip here a play tonight
b-52 early Queen a 6 is an interesting
way to play I is got Quincy eight ok
I'll take everything back and it's got
Quincy 8 forgot about that one Quincy
eight ok then this is right but I'm
probably this is too slow yeah this is
too slow I must play whoopsie one
this is better this is better yeah the
idea is still a 396 and if he goes rook
c8 now this is the main point I can take
and take a seven so he will do something
else probably a 6 and after that I can
play book c2 and then we'll see one and
a half the C file my bishop on the two I
can always activate on on be4 on edge
from and this weakness on c6 is the main
main problem caused by this b6 move if
we wouldn't it would have the porn on b7
set of b6 black would be perfectly all
right but here I'm getting the C file
note that this is not possible at all
because I can even just grab the pawn
it's not just a positional thing and
this means Roxy one is coming and Roxy
six on the horizon it's a very good
position for white I don't really think
that b6 is so great just this is set up
here it's not so great I think alright
thanks for watching